übrigens vor dem vor zwei minuten noch
komplett versammelten bundeskabinett
jetzt hat sie gerade in den letzten zwei
minuten noch die eine oder andere
verschiebung beziehungsweise vertretung
gegeben aber der bundeskanzler ist da
und der erste redner aus der opposition
zu diesem bundeshaushalt ist mathias
middelberg stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion
namen meiner ganzen fraktion herrn
minister lindner unsere besten wünsche
übermitteln wir haben vollstes
verständnis für ihnen wünschen ihm alles
gute
zum haushaltsentwurf 20 23 insgesamt
verdient dieser entwurf kritik und zwar
sehr deutliche kritik ich will aber
einen punkt hervor heben indem ich den
entwurf auch ausdrücklich loben will und
zwar ist das das ziel einhaltung der
schuldenbremse das haben sie selber her
tonga angesprochen dass das von manchen
für einen fetisch gehalten wird
denselben begriff habe ich mir in meinem
rede entwurf auch notiert ja nur das
müssen sie natürlich mit ihren eigenen
leuten in ihrer eigenen koalition
ausmachen das müssen sie mit herrn mütze
nicht diskutieren mit fresken mit frau
aus also vielleicht unterhalten sie sich
mit denen noch mal darüber was die
schuldenbremse eigentlich bedeutet denn
das haben sie hier ganz vernünftig
erklärt und in der nullzinsphase kann
man da vielleicht noch darüber lächeln
in der aktuellen phase in der wir für
unsere kredite wieder geld bezahlen
müssen nämlich zinsen werden uns in
jedem folgejahr dann diese zinsen fehlen
mit denen wir hätten politik gestalten
können für 100 milliarden die sie jetzt
neu aufnehmen und sie nehmen im
laufenden jahr 140 milliarden neue
schulden auf für diese 100 milliarden
die sie beispielsweise neu aufnehmen
fehlen ihm in jedem jahr 1,5 milliarden
die sich für zinsen zahlen müssen das
ist genau der betrag den sie für das
nahverkehrsticket jetzt aufwenden wollen
jedes jahr das zeigt wie wichtig die
einhaltung der schuldenbremse ist denn
sie würden sich zukunft wenn sie es
nicht einhalten ihrer eigenen
handlungsmöglichkeiten ab dann können
sie nämlich dinge wie nahverkehrsticket
und anderes nicht mehr bezahlen das
sieht man jetzt schon das sieht man
jetzt schon an ihrer finanzplanung im
letzten jahr haben wir für zinsen 4
milliarden aufwenden müssen für die
gesamte bundesschuld in diesem jahr
rechnet ihr minister mit 16 milliarden
und im nächsten jahr mit fast 30
milliarden und das zeigt wie ihnen die
spielräume verengt werden wenn sie
weiter schulden machen deswegen sage ich
ihnen
inflation ist wirklich die schlimmste
und das haben sie auch zu recht gesagt
die schlimmste soziale ungerechtigkeit
ist trifft kleine einkommen und kleine
renten und die bekämpfung der inflation
geht am besten indem sie keine schulden
machen indem sie die schuldenbremse
einhalten die schuldenbremse ist eine
frage der nachhaltigkeit der
inflationsbekämpfung und schuldenbremse
einhalten ist sozial gerechte politik
ihnen gelingt es im nächsten jahr die
schuldenbremse allerdings nur
einzuhalten weil sie die über jahre von
wolfgang schäuble aufgebaute asyl
rücklage praktisch in einem jahr
verraten von den 48 milliarden verplanen
sie allein im nächsten jahr über 40
milliarden nur deshalb gelingt ihnen die
einhaltung der schuldenbremse nachhaltig
ist das nicht besonders dramatisch
sind ihre unzureichenden ansätze im
bereich der sozialversicherung wir haben
rekordbeschäftigung in diesem land wir
haben rekord steuereinnahmen und
trotzdem sind wir nicht in der lage bei
dieser sache wirklich guten
wirtschaftlichen situation unsere
sozialversicherungen zu finanzieren wir
können die rente daraus nicht bezahlen
wir können die krankenversicherung nicht
mehr bezahlen wir können auch die
pflegeversicherung daraus nicht
finanzieren
wir haben selber in dem thema ist sagt
das ganz offen gerade beim thema rente
dinge auch geschoben als union ich sage
das ganz offen der unterschied ist nur
wir haben mit dem thema kein wahlkampf
gemacht ihr bundeskanzler der jetzt
leider nicht mehr unter uns ist hat
dieses thema als wahlkampfthema verkauft
er hat sich plakatieren lassen als
kanzler für sichere renten wenn wir uns
jetzt ansehen was sie bisher in diesem
bereich geleistet auch nur vereinbart
haben in ihrem koalitionsvertrag dann
ist das genau gar nichts sie haben nur
ziele festgeschrieben sie wollen das
rentenalter stabil halten sie wollen das
rentenniveau stabil halten und die
beiträge sollen stabil bleiben wie sie
das leisten wollen schreiben sie an
keiner stelle
das ist extrem unglaubhaft und es ist
noch unglaubhaft
die altersentwicklung in diesem land
ansehen wenn sie sehen dass weil die
geburtenstarken jahrgänge dann in die
rente gehen dann wird das gesamte system
zusammenbrechen und dafür herr kindler
haben sie 0 vorsorge getroffen das ist
die wirklichkeit reflektieren
kanzler hat von respekt gesprochen im
wahlkampf ich sage ihnen respekt wäre
wenn er sich dieses großen thema
sicherung der alterssicherung mal
endlich annehmen
thema thema entlastungspaket das haben
sie ja diese woche auch richtig schön
medienwirksam am sonntag verkauft und
sie schreiben dann in diesem papier was
sie dazu veröffentlicht haben die
begrenzten finanziellen spielräume
erfordern erhebliche anstrengung aller
drei koalitionspartner aller ressorts
dass sie da viele anstrengungen hatten
glaube ich ihnen sogar nur der satz
macht den eindruck sie hätten jetzt mal
wirklich im haushalt umschichten oder
schmerzhafter einschränkungen
vorgenommen als sie hätten zeitenwende
wirklich umgesetzt das haben sie 0 und
was sie jetzt zurück verteilen über
entlastungen das ist das was sie den
leuten vorher über steuern aus der
tasche gezogen haben das ist die
wirklichkeit wir haben in diesem jahr
durch die enorm gestiegenen preise das
kann doch jeder der tanks sehen die
preise sind enorm nach oben gegangen und
wenn sie darauf jetzt 19 prozent
umsatzsteuer rechnet nimmt der staat
natürlich irre viel mehr an umsatzsteuer
nein sie haben bis ende juli erste
sieben monate schon 30 milliarden
insgesamt eingenommen davon steht die
hälfte dem bund zu jahresende werden 50
milliarden für den gesamtstaat seien 24
milliarden für den bund über die kalte
progression wie sie im nächsten jahr
ausgleichen wollen aber in diesem jahr
einfach mal so ein kassieren das ist
nämlich die wirklichkeit nehmen sie
nochmals zehn milliarden nur beim und
ein das ist gleich mehr
zusammengerechnet als die 32 milliarden
die herr lindner groß verkauft als der
anteil des bundes am entlastungspaket
also das ist nix mit wirkliche
entlastung sondern dass es linke tasche
rechte tasche und zum thema gasanlage
habt ihr bundeskanzler gesagt mit diesem
schritt die absenkung der mehrwertsteuer
von 19 auf 7 entlasten wir die gaskunden
insgesamt deutlich stärker als die
mehrbelastung die durch die gasanlage
entsteht an diesem satz stimmt genau gar
nichts überhaupt nichts die leute zahlen
jetzt die gasverbraucher zahlen die
gasanlage jetzt oben drauf und weil sich
der gaspreis jetzt schon vor drei oder
vervierfacht hat ist doch klar dass
selbst bei abgesunken mehrwertsteuer sie
dann auf den dreifach höheren betrag
auch bei gesenkte mehrwertsteuer mehr
mehrwertsteuer ergebniszahlen würden ist
doch ganz einfach das kann jeder
schwachkopf rechnen wenn sie aber
wirklich wenn sie eine gasrechnung
vorher von 1000 euro hatten und haben
darauf 19 prozent gezahlt haben sie 190
euro bezahlt an steuern wenn sie jetzt
die dreifach höhere gasrechnung haben
von 3000 euro zahlen darauf sieben dann
zahlen sie jetzt 210 euro sie belasten
die leute noch zusätzlich was der
kanzler gesagt hat ist absoluter
schwachsinn das muss man mal so deutlich
sagen ich weiß nicht der hat wirklich
nicht nur überrascht durch seine
erinnerungslücken in den letzten monaten
sondern jetzt hat auch noch probleme
beim rechnen vielleicht helfen sie ihm
damals
ihr paket kommen viel zu spät den ganzen
sommer über haben sie verplempert durch
streitereien und durch unendlichen zank
in ihrer koalition und sie haben eben
gesprochen was kann man tun um die
inflation zu bekämpfen ja gerade beim
thema energie kann man an die
angebotsseite denken was die fdp hoffen
sehen die auch tut lobenswerterweise ihr
gerade entlaufener wirtschaftsminister
tut das leider nicht wir würden uns
freuen wenn er hier noch zuhören würde
denn er ist der hauptbetroffene diesem
stresstest der hwk veranstaltet hat das
ist doch völliger blödsinn
er hat nur getestet ob die
netzstabilität durch den betrieb dieser
kraftwerke der drei kernkraftwerke die
noch laufen gesichert ist darum alleine
geht es doch gar nicht hätte den
stresstest auch machen müssen im
hinblick darauf wie wirkt es sich
wirtschaftlich aus nämlich auf den
strompreis wie wirkt es sich aus auf das
thema gas sparen das wären doch die
relevanten fragen gewesen die leute mit
denen ich im wahlkreis zu tun habe
mittelständler bäckereien einzelhändler
stahlunternehmen das ich letzte woche
kommen sie bietet im schlesischen bezugs
rechnungen die neuen ihre angebote
vorgelegt da geht es um strom da geht es
um das zehn bis zwölffache des
strompreises habig sagt wir hätten
keinen strom problem doch wir haben 1 er
muss sich da ganz zügig korrigieren
mathias middelberg will die
unionsfraktion naturgemäß nur begrenzt
einverstanden mit dem haushaltsentwurf
23 und auch nicht mit vielen punkten des
entlastungspaket vom wochenende und das
macht er teilweise mit drastischen
worten empathisch und zugewandte über zu
begehen hat er nochmal darauf verwiesen
dass christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister heute nicht hier
sein kann wegen eines privaten
trauerfalls in der familie
nächster redner hier am pult in dieser
allgemeinen finanzdebatte ist denn es
wurde der haushälter der spd fraktion
er hat entfallen an eine andere fraktion
in diesem haus erinnert ich hoffe dass
das
und warum vielleicht auch das noch mal
der beginn ihrer rede wo sie über
zinsbelastung und schulden gesprochen
haben der wäre gut gewesen wenn sie eine
komplett neue fraktion im deutschen
bundestag gewesen wenn die noch nie
regierungsverantwortung hat dieser
starter 1,5 millionen schulden sie haben
die meiste zeit regiert wenn sie mit dem
finger auf andere zeigt zeigen
mindestens vier finger zurück liebe
kolleginnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es gab in den
letzten tagen eine gute nachricht die
füllstände unserer gasspeicher haben die
wichtige marke von 85 prozent erreicht
das ist nur möglich gewesen weil die
regierungen in den letzten monaten
besonnen reagiert hat und nicht dem
aktionismus einiger verfahren ist die im
märz schon alle gasleitungen nach osten
dicht machen wollte uns würden
gigawattstunden anspruch an gas geben
das wäre fatal für dieses land gewesen
ich bin dieser bundesregierung dankbar
dass sie das problem nicht multipliziert
hat vor dem wir stehen und so besonnen
reagiert hat liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich glaube wir alle jede bürgerin jeder
bürger hätte sich ein bisschen ruhe nach
der pandemie gewünscht wir alle hätten
uns gewünscht dass nach den zwei sehr
intensiven krisenjahren jetzt ruhigere
zeiten eintreten aber mal wieder hat uns
die realität neu konfrontiert und ich
glaube wir sollten an diesem punkt auch
zurück gucken wie wir die letzten krisen
bewältigt haben 2008 2009 ist dieses
land in eine große finanz und
wirtschaftskrise geraten und es ist
nicht aus dieser krise herausgekommen
weil der staat gefragt hat wer kann das
dem problem denn lösen ist jemand bereit
es anzugehen sondern weil der staat
selbst das heft des handelns in die hand
genommen hat weil wir das
kurzarbeitergeld ausgewiesen haben weil
wir die einlagen der sparer weil wir die
spareinlagen sicher gestellt haben
damals hat uns ein starker staat aus
dieser krise geholfen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
20.20 die korona pandemie über uns
hereingebrochen ist hat der staat wieder
nicht gefragt wer kann uns denn helfen
wer handelt denn dass arbeitsplätze und
wirtschaft erhalten bleiben sondern es
war wieder ein starker staat der
gehandelt hat der rettungspakete in noch
nie dagewesener größenordnung gestört
hat der kurzarbeiter geld mobilisiert
hat und wieder war es ein starker staat
der uns durch diese krise gebracht hat
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und das
was uns durch die letzten krisen
gebracht hat das muss auch blaupause für
diese krise sein ich sage auch für die
fraktion der spd wir brauchen jetzt
wieder einen starken staat der die
bürgerinnen und bürger nicht alleine
lässt nur gemeinsam vom gestärkt durch
diese krise liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir brauchen jetzt ein staat der wie
auch in den letzten beiden krisen
bereites jobs um arbeitsplätze zu
sichern aber eben auch ein der bereit
ist den bürgerinnen und bürgern bei den
explodierenden energiepreisen zur seite
zu stehen und genau das tun wir in den
letzten monaten genau das tun wir seit
kriegsbeginn und genau das hat die
koalition am wochenende mit dem nächsten
entlastungspaket vorgelegt wir wir haben
erneut direktzahlungen vereinbaren an
die rentnerinnen und rentner an die
studierenden um zumindest einen teil der
mehrkosten aufzufangen
wir nehmen familien in den blick durch
ein höheres kindergeld und durch einen
höheren kinderzuschlag ein wichtiges
signal an alle familien in diesem land
wir weiten
wir beiden massiv das wohngeld aus wir
machen das kurzfristig aber auch
langfristig angelehnt und leben
abzuwenden dass menschen in eine
existenzbedrohende situation kommen die
jetzt schon sehr knapp dran sind ist
auch ein wichtiges signal eines starken
eines handelnden staates liebe kollegen
und ich
finde die debatte um die co2 abgabe die
einige wissenschaftler gerade führen
auch sehr spannend wir haben gesagt die
co2 abgabe ist dafür da eine
lenkungswirkung zu entfalten aber in
zeiten immens wo er energiepreise es
richtig zu sagen die erhöhung setzen wir
aus die verschieben wir erstmal weil die
preise schon so los sind und wenn dann
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von einem fatalen signal sprechen und
die lenkungswirkung als abhandenkommen
ansehen dann frage ich mich in welcher
wirklichkeit die leben jetzt geht es
darum bürgerinnen und bürger zu
entlasten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir sind bereit als bund auch wenn
es verfassungsrechtlich nicht unsere
aufgabe ist ein nachfolge ticket für das
neue euro ticket mitzufinanzieren
aber an der stelle liegt die betonung
auf mitzufinanzieren wir sind bereit 1,5
milliarden euro zur verfügung zu stellen
und ich hoffe dass die länder damit
machen und dass wir gemeinsam ein
erfolgreiches nachfolger ticket auf den
weg bringen wir
haben uns darauf verständigt auch
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgebern
gemeinsam mit arbeitnehmerinnen und
nehmer eine verständigung möglich zu
machen die eine einmalzahlung möglich
macht die dann komplett steuer und
abgabenfrei ist auch das ist ein
wichtiges signal und jahr das alles wird
geld kosten
das alles wird den bundeshaushalt
belasten das alles wird die
länderhaushalte belasten das alles wird
den klima und transformations- form
belasten da kommt eine große
finanzierungs aufgabe auf uns zu aber
ich finde es gilt genau dasselbe was
2008 und 2009 gegolten hat es gilt genau
dasselbe was
2020/2021 bedeuten hat wenn wir jetzt
nichts tun würden dann wird es für den
staat am ende wesentlich teurer werden
und dann würde es auch für die
bürgerinnen und bürger wesentlich teurer
werden wir müssen jetzt handeln
kolleginnen und kollegen
und
wir schieben die finanzierung eben nicht
in die zukunft ich meine wir leben das
ja gerade am strommarkt da ist aufgrund
der der marktmechanismus grad
marktmechanismen gerade eine situation
dass der strompreis deutlich nach oben
geht aber unternehmen die billig strom
zb aus erneuerbaren einkaufen können
milliarden gewinne und umsätze machen
und wir sagen jetzt eben nicht wir
kompensieren dass in dem der bunte
einspringt und neue schulden macht die
dann irgendwann ab 20 28 oder so von den
danach folgenden generationen bezahlt
werden müssen sondern uns ist klar wer
zufalls gewinner hat in einer krise der
muss sie auch zur verfügung stellen
damit der stromkreis nicht durch die
decke geht auch das soziale
verantwortung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und es gehört auch zur wahrheit dass es
gerade zurecht angesprochen worden die
inflation bleibt natürlich auch die
umsatzsteuereinnahmen des bundes und ich
glaube die menschen haben ein sehr
feines gefühl dafür ob wir das was wir
von anderen fordern nämlich dass sie
bereit sind ihre über gewinne wieder
zurückzugeben ob wir auch selbst dazu
bereit sind deshalb ist es richtig dass
der bund sagt das was wir an
mehrwertsteuer mehr einnahmen haben das
was wir quasi als zufalls gewinner als
über gewinne haben das geben wir auch an
die bürgerinnen und bürger zurück und
ich finde wenn ich jetzt den einen oder
anderen ministerpräsidenten höhere zb
herrn wüst aus nrw das gilt auch für die
landeshaushalte kriegen nämlich 52
prozent designer und ich finde auch die
haben eine verantwortung an die das bild
der bundeshaushalt ist im volumen 50
milliarden euro geringer als im letzten
jahr und wenn andere reagiert hätten und
das getan hätten was sie im letzten
haushalt gefordert haben nämlich die
rücklage komplett aufzulösen dann hätten
wir jetzt eine situation dass es nicht
50 milliarden wäre sondern es wären 90
milliarden nur weil wir über jahre dafür
gesorgt haben dass wir die rücklage dann
einsetzen können wenn wir die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten schaffen
wir es eine abbruchkante eine soziale
abbruchkante in diesem land verhindern
dass es vorausschauende politik in den
letzten jahren gewesen und das zahlt
sich heute aus liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir stehen vor haushaltsverhandlungen
die erneut von großen unsicherheiten
behaftet sind wir wissen nicht wie sich
die zinsen in den nächsten wochen und
monaten entwickeln werden wir wissen
nicht gesichert wie sich die inflation
wie sich das wirtschaftswachstum unseres
landes entwickeln wird wir wissen nicht
was sich aus den arbeitsmarkt der
arbeitsmarktsituation heraus in den
sozialversicherungssystemen abspielen
wird wir werden eventuelle auf weitere
dinge reagieren müssen zb auch im
internationalen kontext und deshalb sage
ich auch für unsere fraktion wir sind
bereit in den nächsten monaten in den
haushaltsverhandlungen auch auf die sich
verändernden ausgangslagen zu reagieren
am ende muss die botschaft sein wir
lassen die bürgerinnen und bürger nicht
alleine nur gemeinsam sind wir stark in
dieser krise und das muss über allem
stehen in den nächsten wochen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wie mehrere aufgabe ist es dieses land
gut durch die krise zu bekommen dass das
schwerpunkt der nächsten wochen und
monaten und dafür setzen wir uns ein
kinder
dennis rohde der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion in der
allgemeinen finanzdebatte die in die
debatten
tage im deutschen bundestag zum
bundeshaushalt 23 eröffnet da sehen und
hören wie jetzt peter böhringer den
haushaltspolitischen sprecher der
fdp-fraktion
präsidentin wir sprechen heute über
einen vermutlich nur kurzlebigen
haushaltsentwurf 2023 falls er
tatsächlich im november so wie geplant
verabschiedet werden sollte steuert der
finanzminister trotz illegaler rücklagen
von über 200 milliarden euro und trotz
wir haben ja eben gehört
inflationsbedingte gewaltiger steuer
mehreinnahmen zu lassen der deutschen
bürger auf einen nachtragshaushalt 23 zu
sie ist heute eigentlich schon relativ
wahrscheinlich warum natürlich wegen der
energie
kostenexplosion die dümmste
energiepolitik der welt führt in
deutschland heute zu den höchsten
stromkosten der welt
sie ist sowohl gegenüber den bürgern als
auch gegenüber der deutschen industrie
absolut verantwortungslos die
preiskurven spotten jeder beschreibung
und werden zu massen insolvenzen und
verarmung führen
die regierung ist dabei uns nicht nur
frieren zu lassen sondern unsere
wirtschaft zu zerstören 50 des erdgases
gehen in zentralen industrien
düngemittel nahrungsmittelproduktion
verpackungsindustrie metallverarbeitung
schon heute wandern jeden tag betriebe
ab oder
eben auf etwa die swk stickstoff
priester rizone der in adblue für lkws
könnten sogar logistikketten brechen die
folgen wären verheerend
wir müssen sogar über strommangel
sprechen die ampel wird im winter in
einem großen experiment mit uns als
versuchskaninchen versuchen durch
kontrollierte teil abschaltungen
blackouts zu vermeiden
dann wären wir auf dem niveau eines
entwicklungslandes
angekommen
energie energie ist das lebens blut
einer modernen wirtschaft ideologen und
ignoranten die von technologie und
ökonomie keine ahnung haben denn ist es
in 40 jahren fehlgeleiteter
energiepolitik gelungen die deutsche
wirtschaft an den rand dieser
katastrophe zu führen
übrigens über 30 jahre cdu-geführte
die deutschen sparkassen rechnen damit
dass schon bald 60 prozent der deutschen
ihre gesamten einkünfte oder mehr für
die reine lebenshaltung aufwenden oder
einsetzen müssen das wird die
lebensplanung all dieser menschen völlig
verändern armut ohne spielraum für
eigene lebensgestaltung ist schrecklich
spätestens im nächsten jahr wird dann
erneut die schuldenobergrenze der
verfassung gerissen faktisch herr
staatssekretär tun sie das auch in
diesem jahr bereits mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf der bundesrechnungshof
hat es ihnen eben noch einmal
vorgerechnet ich habe das schon vor über
monaten getan sie reißen sie um das
vierfache aber fällt heute die zeit
dafür es ist also schlichtweg nicht wahr
über sie minuten lang geredet haben das
die letzten endes die schuldengrenze
einhalten wenn es zum nachtragshaushalt
kommt sowieso nicht mehr
ja und dann mal sehen welche
notsituation diesmal dann als begründung
herhalten muss vermutlich wird ist ja
just jener energienotstand sein den sie
selbst herbeigeführt haben den ist ohne
die ihre energie und geopolitik der
ampel und der groko so nie gegeben hätte
den ausstieg aus der kernenergie den
rein ideologischen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien die verkündeten
sanktionen und die waffenlieferungen
gegen deutsche interessen die im winter
kommende mangelverwaltung und das
inflations desaster sind politik gemacht
und sie gehen auf das konto aller
altparteien denn auch die cdu csu wird
nicht so tun können als habe es den
merkelschen ausstiegsbeschluss aus der
modernen sicheren heute fast
rückstandsfreien kernenergie nicht
gegeben und die union trägt auch
verantwortung für den fatalen green deal
für diese fatalen fehlentscheidungen
gegen kohle gegen öl und nun auch noch
gegen gas
die verknappung der co2 zertifikate war
politisch gewollt der preis pro tonne
lag schon vor dem angriff putins auf die
ukraine bei über 90 euro
experten professor fahrenholz spricht
ist klar aus der ausstieg aus
kernenergie und kohle funktioniert die
nur weil wir im hintergrund immer mehr
russisches gas zu führten lange vor dem
ukraine krieg sonst wäre die
energiewende schon vor jahren
gescheitert wenn die pipelines nicht
schnellstmöglich wieder gas
transportieren sind in deutschland 6
millionen arbeitsplätze gefährdet wir
sind dabei unsere industrie zu zerstören
wenn sie north stream und damit grund
schlagball günstiges pipelinegas nicht
nutzen wird genau das passieren
eine regierung die sagt kein gas aus
russland obwohl jetzt ihre eigene
politik diese abhängigkeit von russland
herbeigeführt hat grüne politik ist
entweder weltfremd oder gar vorsätzlich
gegen deutschland gerichtet weil ich
inzwischen gehören natürlich ist das
grüne politik gewesen ist war grüne
politik denn es war ökonomisch sinnvoll
die ein flatter strom aus den
erneuerbaren energien zu kompensieren
mit dem einzig möglichen das war da die
gaskraftwerke die schnell rauf und
runter regelbar sind nur so deshalb sind
sie persönlich alle zumindest sobald
sich jetzt in der regierung sind aber
damals ja auch schon einfluss hatten
schon mit schuld daran an dieser
geschichte
ja am ende profitiert russland sogar
davon sanktionen die ampel regierung
verzichtet zum beispiel auf langfristige
kohlelieferungen aus russland die einen
bruchteil des heutigen preises gekostet
hätten man verzichtet in der jetzigen
situation darauf wo russland kann die
kohle anderweitig zum achtfachen preis
verkaufen dabei hat russland bereits
heute die weltbeste handelsbilanz und so
wollen sie russland in die knie zwingen
das ist irre
falls sie ernsthaft in wenigen monaten
die letzten drei dann noch verbliebenen
deutschen kraft kernkraftwerke
abschalten dann wäre das gleichbedeutend
mit dem abriss von 10.000 windräder
eigentlich sogar noch mehr denn die
windräder liefern ja nur flattr strom
und auch deshalb braucht man noch mehr
reservekapazität und auch das ist
natürlich unfug
und die eu in ihrer unendlichen
boshaftigkeit verschärft die
preisspirale bei energie sogar noch sie
zieht ihr absurdes programm fit for
fifty five nicht zurück 1 vor zu lasten
deutschlands mit dem die grüne co2
religion in der ganzen eu durchgesetzt
werden sollte deutsche steuerzahler
sollen die energie umstellung in anderen
eu-ländern subventionieren bei deutschen
verbrauchern dürfen sich die
energiepreis rechnungen offensichtlich
verfünffachen das stört die ampel nicht
in der eu stört es ihn ja und hinter
auch in abwesenheit diese mahnung an sie
sie haben die interessen der deutschen
zu vertreten der deutsche haushalt kann
es nicht verkraften wenn sie nicht
endlich die energieprobleme ursächlich
angehen ursächlich und eben nicht
symptomatisch wie wir es jetzt am
wochenende wieder gehört haben die
volkswirtschaftlichen mehr kosten für
energie gegenüber 2020 das ist das
vergleichsjahr betragen bei heutigen
future preisen
250 milliarden euro pro jahr
das ist die auf basis
des jetzigen future preises
60 prozent eines bundeshaushalts dagegen
verblasst jede gas umlage das ist
eigentlich ein nebenkriegsschauplatz
das stimmt sogar das deutsche kredit
buch nicht der steuerzahler nicht mehr
man kann diese summen nicht mehr mit
entlastungs paketen auffangen hier hilft
nur ein regierungswechsel und endlich
eine rationale energiepolitik die es
langfristig nur mit der afg geben kann
konnte die zum schluss ist der präsident
die einmal für deutschland wenn das
bedeutet diese rot-grüne regierung
sofort zu verlassen nun denn es ist
besser nicht zu regieren als falsch zu
regieren herzlichen dank
peter böhringer haushaltspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion mit seiner
sicht auf energiepolitik und russland im
besonderen sven christian kindler ist
der nächste redner kommt aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und ist
ein weiterer haushaltspolitischer
sprecher der wiesn
2009 mitglied im haushaltsausschuss und
ich glaube alle kolleginnen kollegen im
haus des autos wissen das wären die
schwersten haushaltsberatungen seit
jahrzehnten
das liegt daran dass einfach wir
verschiedene krisen gleichzeitig
auftreten wir haben die brutalen
schrecklichen angriffskrieg russlands
gegen die ukraine mit der massiven
inflation die daraus folgt bei gas noch
bei öl wir sehen dass das international
schwere verwerfungen hat putin hunger
als waffe einsetzt gleichzeitig haben
wir immer noch eine gesundheitskrise
durch die krone anämie und wir haben den
vierten hitzesommer in fünf jahren
erlebt die schlimmste dürre in europa
seit 50 jahren und all das hat massive
auswirkungen auf die gesellschaft auch
die wirtschaft und auch diesen haushalt
und in der koalition in diesem
parlamentarischen haushaltsverhandlungen
ist klar wir stellen uns diesen krisen
entschlossen wir ducken sich weg und
gehen die probleme entschlossen an
und deswegen es ist richtig und gut dass
der koalitionsausschuss am wochenende
ein großes paket beschlossen hat trotz
aller politischen unterschiede die auch
normal sind eine demokratie hat diese
koalition am wochenende gezeigt dass sie
gemeinsam handlungsfähig ist und mit 65
milliarden euro großes bewegen kann das
zählt am ende in der demokratie
damit helfen wir vielen wir helfen
kleine mittleren unternehmen wir helfen
familie mit dem kinderzuschlag und dem
kindergeld wir helfen wir wollten das
wohngeld aus wer entlasten rennen und
rentner studierende schülerinnen wir
führen bundesweit ein dauerhaftes
günstiges ticket für den öffentlichen
nahverkehr ein und es wird die größte
erhöhung der eiger zwei regelsätze geben
seit bestehen des systems das kann sich
sehen lassen dieses paket
und natürlich gibt es auch punkte die
wir anders entschieden hätten stellen
ihr co2 preiswerten höheres bürgergeld
vorstellen können auch das thema kalte
progression aber das wird sich das wesen
von kompromissen dass man sich einigen
muss und dass ein guter kompromiss wolle
die richtige richtung geht die menschen
die mit kleinen mittleren einkommen
leiden am stärksten unter das fossil
getrieben inflation wenn man sich die
zahlen anguckt entlassen will sie am
aller deutlichsten am meisten und
gleichzeitig haben wir
und gleichzeitig hat kollege rohde
darauf hingewiesen schöpfen wir zufalls
gewinne ab im strommarkt von unternehmen
die es nicht brauchen und finanzieren
teil dieses paket das ist richtig und
gerecht
und die schweren krisen die wir zu
bewältigen haben sie eine
gesamtstaatliche aufgabe der bund ist
bereits an teil dafür zu tun und es ist
klar noch mal zu sagen die länder
inzwischen mehr steuern als der bund 20
21 und 20 22 klaren im gegensatz zum
bund trotzdem mit extrem wenig
notkrediten und ich finde die länder die
jetzt egal welche farbe übrigens unisono
groß entlastungspaket gefordert haben
die sondern auch ihren fairen beitrag
zur finanzierung dieser leistungspakete
machen dass es nur gerecht
ich bin aber auch die kritik der union
eingehen zu den leistungspaketen warum
brauchen wir überhaupt so hohe
entlastungspaket weil wir sind nur wo
fossil betriebene inflation haben vor
allen dingen bei gas und vor allen
dingen bei öl und das ist er war die
wahrheit warum wir jetzt so eine massive
krise haben wir hatten an 16 jahre lang
regiert wer hat denn der energiewende
blockiert wer hat denn wind und solar
sabotiert wo ist nun gegenwert die
gebäudesanierung verschlafen die wärme
und wände nicht vorangetrieben wer hat
und abhängig von putins gras gemacht hat
16 jahre regierungspolitik union sie
haben muss eine erhebliche
scherbenhaufen zu erlassen als koalition
und wir ändern das jetzt im rekordtempo
mit zehn gesetzen zur erneuerbaren
energien und energiesicherheit hier vor
dem sommer nach beschlossen haben und
dann bitte berg ich empfehle ihnen sich
ernsthaft mal den stress der ist genau
einfach mal durch zu lesen weil man sich
genau angucken haben sie nicht gemacht
können sich angucken
0,4 klasse mit dem berg 0,1 prozent
weniger als 0,1 prozent hätte einen
schreck betrieb von akw eine effekt auf
die frage des gasverbrauchs also de
facto gar nichts führende energie
führen energiemarkt experten haben sehr
klar berechnet dass auch ist keine
signifikanten effekt auf den preis gäbe
waren nämlich jetzt im jetziges team die
höchst- und kraftwerken höchsten preisen
dem kreis zustimmen im merit order
effekt und nicht die atomkraftwerke und
am letzten
der stress hat sehr klar geben dass wir
keine streck betrieb brauchen und keine
laufzeitverlängerung worum es jetzt geht
das im rekordtempo unabhängig machen von
putins graz versuchen mit ihren
atomdebatten davon abzulenken menschen
scherbenhaufen erlassen haben das wäre
wenig durchgehen lassen
[Applaus]
im gegenteil sie wollen ist ja dass wir
weiter habe ich gesagt putins gassi
klagen ja gerade auch in karlsruhe gegen
den transformations- und klimafonds der
als unabhängig macht energieeffizienter
uns unabhängig macht dem wir die
industrie an bauern in dem wir
klimaschutz vorantreiben gegen der ihre
politik wieder dazu führen dass ihr
weiter april war putin öl und gas und
das werden wir nicht zulassen
die letzten wochen und monate haben es
gezeigt wir müssen diesen
haushaltsberatungen bei diesem schweren
herbst und winter davon steht ein stück
wird auch auf sicht fahren weil wir noch
nicht alle auswirkungen kennen kollege
oder darauf hingewiesen wir wissen noch
nicht wie sich die korona pandemie sehr
schreckliche krieg auf unsere
gesellschaft auch die wirtschaft auf
unsere öffentlichen haushalte auswirkt
auch international sehen wir dass wir
noch deutlichen nachholbedarf haben beim
thema welternährung beim thema zivile
krisenprävention humanitäre hilfe wenn
ich mit an wo für 23 angucke und die
aktuellen zahlen sehen eher schwierig
aus also das konsumklima geht runter
hatte ifo geschäftsklimaindex ist auf
dem höchsten stand seit zwei jahren
und natürlich ist klar eine situation
braucht man eine aktive gestalten der
fiskalpolitik darauf wären wenn es in
verhandlungen auch im parlament achten
wir werden uns im haushalt und in den
nächsten haushalt als vorratsbeschluss
riesen hineinsparen wir werden das
notwendige das richtige was wir brauchen
auch finanzieren und werden niemand
dieser gesellschaft in dieser schweren
krise im stich lassen vielen dank
sven christian kindler für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen wo er
haushaltspolitischer sprecher ist
haushaltspolitische sprecherin
beziehungsweise stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzenden ist gesine lötzsch
aus der linksfraktion und wir sind immer
noch bei der allgemeinen finanz enten
debatte zum haushalt 23
spekulanten stromhändler waffenhändler
immobilienkonzern und vermögen aber er
ist schlecht für menschen die jeden cent
umdrehen müssen sie werden mit almosen
abgespeist das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren meine damen herren und
dieser haushalt ist schlecht für kleine
und mittlere unternehmen deren existenz
bedroht ist oder die schon aufgeben
mussten diese unternehmen brauchen
wirksame hilfen auch davon ist in diesem
haushalt nichts zu finden das muss sich
ändern
die galoppierende inflation treibt viele
menschen in dramatische probleme sie
wissen nicht mehr wie sie ihre
rechnungen bezahlen sollen aber die
bundesregierung lässt sie im regen
stehen warum weil sie nicht bereit ist
die krisengewinnler wirklich wirksam zu
besteuern stattdessen will sie mit einer
gasanlage
energiekonzern entlasten obwohl viele
von ihnen in den kriegs monaten riesige
gewinne erzielt haben saerbeck nennt sie
nur trittbrettfahrer
nein die wahrheit ist die manager dieser
firmen haben die gasanlage selbst
aufgeschrieben das ist 100% lobbyismus
das nehmen wir nicht hin meine damen und
herren wir
fordern eine über gewinnsteuern die
bereits in vielen anderen ländern
existiert wir könnten mit dieser steuer
100 milliarden euro einnehmen damit
ließen sich gas strom und mieten deckeln
das wäre der richtige weg meine damen
und herren
aber
spd und grüne lassen sich von der fdp
unter druck setzen und verweigern so
steuer seien sie doch mutiger gegenüber
der fdp meine damen und herren
was hilft nun gegen die preisexplosion
auf jeden fall nicht die milden gaben
die sie den menschen am wochenende
versprochen haben nein man muss an die
ursachen der explosion herangehen es
gibt zurzeit auf dieser welt 20 kriege
wir sprechen hier häufig über den krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine und wir
wissen alle dass eine mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land fordert dass
durch eine mutige entschlossene
internationale friedensinitiative dieser
krieg beendet werden muss das leiden der
menschen im krieg in der ukraine muss
beendet werden meine damen und herren
aber schauen wir in den haushalt die
rüstungsindustrie sitz der regierung im
nacken meint sogar 14 also verteidigung
oder rüstung sind 50,1 milliarden euro
für das militär vorgesehen doch in
wirklichkeit sind es nach nato kriterien
berechnet 14 milliarden euro mehr also
64 milliarden euro und wenn wir dieses
geld für kitas schulen universitäten
krankenhäuser sozialen wohnungsbau und
busse und bahnen ausgeben würden dann
würden wir unser land besser
zukunftsfähiger und sicherer machen
meine damen und herren wir haben das
haben die anderen kollegen auch gesagt
in den haushaltsberatungen viel zu tun
der haushalt muss sozial werden er muss
nachhaltig werden und er muss zum
frieden in dieser welt beitragen lange
gesehene lötzsch stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion aber dort
auch haushaltspolitische sprecherin und
vorsitzende eben haushaltsausschuss ist
hier auch schon mal gewesen dass schon
ein bisschen länger her otto fricke ist
am pult der haushaltspolitische sprecher
der fdp fraktion
putin auch nur einen cent weniger
gaspreise nehmen wird in dem moment wo
es sogenannte friedensverhandlungen gibt
das auf dem rücken von opfern in der
ukraine so darzustellen ist eine
verkennung der realität ist eine
verkennung dessen wer schuld an nun
greifen ist und die diese koalition
kostet hier abzufedern man damit wären
das ist der erste haushalt mit
einhaltung der schuldenbremse nach zwei
ausnahme haushalten wenn ich überlege
wie es noch hieß das werdet ihr niemals
schaffen einen haushalt im kabinett
vorzulegen das redet ihr niemals
schaffen bis zum ende der sommerpause
das zu halten er werde es niemals
schaffen wenn ihr ein drittes
entlastungspaket macht noch einigermaßen
hier überhaupt eine solche
schuldenbremse einzuhalten dann kann ich
nur sagen diese koalition hat gezeigt
dass wenn man acht arbeitet wenn man
gegenseitig kompromisse macht und dabei
immer an die menschen denkt dann kann
man auch die verfassung dann kann man
auch den schuldenbremse einhalten und
darüber bin ich sehr froh man damen und
herren
ich sag das auch deutlich ich bin ja
schon ganz froh dass ich von kollegen
mittelberg nichts mehr von seinem
fetisch nämlich von der schwarzen null
gehört habe das war doch das was die cdu
immer wollte ist interessant dass sie
das jetzt nicht mehr sagen und zweiter
punkt in richtung cdu mitte märz sich
sagen aber das wäre ein trick mit der
rücklage wenn sie wirklich der meinung
sind dass wir in notzeiten rücklagen die
für notzeiten sind nicht neben sollen
dann bin ich auf die haushaltsberatungen
mit ihrer fraktion im haushaltsausschuss
gespannt wo sie diese 40 milliarden
einsparen werden und das als zweites in
ihre richtung wir sehen hier und hören
von ihnen auch gleich von anderen redner
der cdu und der einst so stolzen csu ja
da muss man mehr sparen da muss man
vernünftiger sein und wenn sie dann alle
weg sind kommen die fachpolitiker und
sagen ach was interessiert mich das
geschwätz meiner vorgänger vorhin da
macht ihr zu wenig da müsste mehr machen
da mitzumachen da lobe ich mir schon die
ehrlichkeit der linken an der stelle ich
kann ihnen das auch sagen sie ich bleibe
da beim sommernachtstraum und ich glaube
bei ihnen ist da auch so ein bisschen
sommernachtstraum noch hängen geblieben
es ist nicht genug dass man rede man
muss auch richtig reden und da ist ihre
aufgabe als opposition uns wirklich
vorschläge zu machen und mich einfach
nur zu sagen ich hätte es gerne anders
aber ich weiß eigentlich nicht wie ich
sehe bei der rente probleme ich weiß
aber nicht wie ich sehe an ganz vielen
stellen bei der energieprobleme ich weiß
aber nicht wie es böse machen sie doch
mal einen alternativen durchgerechneten
echten anderen lösungsvorschlag dann
gehen wir auch gerne mit ihnen allen in
die debatte meine damen und herren es
ist
es ist dann auch noch mal angesprochen
worden und das sage ich auch weil die
banken natürlich wieder leer ist ich
meine ich bin auch nicht darüber erfreut
dass nachdem der kollege tonga hier
einbringt nach einer nach dem anderen
die minister verschwinden und die
sicherlich leistungsfähigen
parlamentarischen staatssekretär hier
sitzen aber was auch der bundesratsbank
passiert ist wieder typisch wir erleben
das und ich sage das für alle egal wer
jetzt in der regierung oder jetzt in der
opposition ist das ist ja das schöne
demokratie dass das mal wechselt wenn es
so weiter gehen wird dass die länder
immer wieder sagen ich bin zwar
zuständig die verfassung hat mir auch
die erträge dafür gegeben aber es soll
gefälligst der bund alles zahlen dann
wird dieser bundeshaushalt interessiert
sein und ich hätte erwartet dass von
ihnen dazu in erinnerung an den kollegen
rehberg den wir alle an der stelle immer
unterstützt haben egal ob in der
opposition der regierung werden etwas
mehr gekommen wäre dass wir hier auch
stehen denn die verhandlungen die da
gebe ich dem kollegen
vollkommen rechts von christian kindler
die verhandlungen werden ja nicht nur
hier geführt sie werden ja auch noch mit
dem ministerpräsidenten geführtes wird
nach achte haushaltsberatungen werden
ich bin gespannt was an vorschlägen
kommt ich fürchte von dieser bank werden
keine guten vorschläge kommen versuchen
sie es ein wenig die hoffnung ist da die
regierung hat ihre vorlagen gemacht das
parlament wird seine arbeit tun und ich
bin mir sicher dass wenn wir im november
über den haushalt reden werden alle
erkennen es ist der haushalt einer
stabilen sozialen marktwirtschaft aber
es gibt keine weihnachtsgeschenke denn
ende november steht es im gesetz
herzlichen dank
otto fricke der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion und zehn zum
thema bund länder und finanzen vom bund
an die länder hat der bundesrechnungshof
in seinem bericht zu diesem haushalt
auch ein paar anmerkungen gemacht unter
anderem hat er den bund vorgehalten dass
durch die steuerverteilung dem bund von
22 bis 26 rund 100 milliarden euro durch
verzichte zugunsten der länder entgehen
zusätzlich so heißt es finanziere der
bund länder ausgaben mit zweifelhafter
wirksamkeit das am rande sebastian brehm
ist derweil ans pult getreten sprecher
für haushalt und finanzen der
csu-landesgruppe
die neuverschuldung ist mit rund 78
milliarden euro 4 fach höher als im
bundeshaushalts plan ausgewiesen liebe
kollegen und kollegen deshalb wichtig
sondern das sagt der bundesrechnungshof
und hat es ihnen in die bücher
geschrieben für liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der ampel und wenn der
bundesrechnungshof so was sagt dann
treibt in die tiefe sorge um die zukunft
deutschlands und diese tiefe sorge teile
ich liebe kollegin kollegen der haushalt
ist eine reine mogelpackung der
finanzminister verkündet 17,2 milliarden
neuverschuldung
sie entnehmen 40 5 milliarden aus der
asyl rücklage und greifen noch auf die
gesammelten 60 milliarden aus dem
nachtragshaushalt
2021 zu wir klagen dagegen liebe
kollegen und kollegen das ist
intransparente und unseriöse
haushaltspolitik
liebe kollegen auch bei regen
investitionen verkünden sie an den
rekordwert aber rechnet man es mal
sauber raus also die zuzahlungen die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung die
zahlungen den klimafonds des iwf dann
haben wir die niedrigsten investitionen
und wer hätte gedacht dass die grünen
sogar eine verringerung der
investitionen in die schiene vornehmen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und darüber hinaus fehlt in dem haushalt
gänzlich das was sie am wochenende
beschlossen haben 65 milliarden euro sie
haben zehn milliarden euro pauschal
eingeplant was machen sie mit den
restlichen 55 milliarden wer soll das
bezahlen bund länder kommunen kein wort
im laufenden haushalts gelegen einen
haushalt vor der von an dann nicht
stimmt liebe kollegen und kollegen und
fangen sie nicht an uns die ganze
situation in die schuhe zu schieben die
spd war übrigens den letzten jahren auch
in der regierung ich weiß dass
vergesslichkeit grad bei der spd und
beim bundeskanzler gerade im moment
mainstream sind aber wir haben 16 jahre
lang bewiesen dass wirtschaftspolitik
wachstum beschäftigung und solide
finanzen zusammen gehören wir haben die
wirtschaftskrise 2008 2009 gemeistert
wir haben die korona krise gemeistert
und wir haben insgesamt die
staatsverschuldung gesenkt werden
insgesamt wirtschaftswachstum gehabt
einen gesunden und stabilen mittelstand
und wir hatten die höchsten
beschäftigungszahlen in deutschland und
sie machen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
jetzt die menschen in unserem land
erinnern und den mittelstand liebe
kolleginnen kollegen machen sie gänzlich
kaputt lieber herr kollege ronan das
muss ich schon was sagen wenn sie in
mittelberg gleich in die rechte ecke
stellen wenn er kritik äußert das ist
sie ihre rot grüne mainstream politik
wenn ihnen die meinung nicht passt dann
wird man sofort in die rechte ecke
gestellt sie interessiert doch gar nicht
die kritik der opposition sie haben ein
demokratieverständnis was völlig falsch
am platz ist und die regierung ist ja
gar nicht anwesend wenn die opposition
spricht das ist eigentlich skandalös
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich mache mir große sorgen um den
deutschen mittelstand anstatt die
angebotsseite auch bei der energie zu
erweitern und in den blick zu nehmen
verringern sie bewusst kapazitäten aus
rein ideologische überzeugung stichwort
kernkraftwerke
wunderkinder
wenn sie sagen dass die verlängerung der
kernkraftwerke nicht in ordnung ist dann
haben sie die lage aktuell nicht
begriffen was sie da tun ist
unverantwortlich sie hören ja nicht
immer mehr zu was sie da tun ist
unverantwortlich was sie machen ist auf
kohle zu setzen auf fracking gas an
schwer punkern die nach deutschland
kommen das ist die neue grüne
klimapolitik deutschland liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was sagen sie
den bäcker an dem metzger was sagen sie
dem landwirt der nicht mehr in
deutschland produzieren kann was sagen
sie der lackiererei dem metallbetrieb
den chemiebetrieb der glashütte der
brauerei sie sagen gar nichts denn es
kommt kein einziger vorschlag zur
stützung des mittelstandes zur
entlastung des mittelstandes das einzige
was sie sagen und das ist ja ehrlich
gesagt ein hohen sie von der fdp machen
leider über diesen ganzen spielchen mit
das ist wirklich größ enttäuschend was
sie hier in der bundesregierung
abliefern liebe kolleginnen kollegen der
fdp sie sagen bloß mann soll kfw kredite
aufnehmen diese kfw kredite können die
mittelständler überhaupt nicht mehr
zurückzahlen in der jetzigen lage und
ein großteil der erwerbstätigen muss
zusehen wie sie maroden gaskonzernen
geld ohne jegliche bedingungen zu
chancen zahlen darf der arbeitende
bürger der mittelständler mit der
gasanlage schaffen sie diese gas umlage
ab sie ist unsozial und ungerecht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die fdp wenn wir dann ein jahr wir
machen ja eine entlastung der bürger mit
der kalten progression erstens erst ab
dem jahr 2023 skandalöses müsste im jahr
2022 schon stattfinden und zweitens bis
die kalte progression die entlastung der
kalten progression keine entlastung
sollen es eine abwanderung der belastung
die sie den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zumuten wir haben es ja schon gesagt die
steuereinnahmen sind 16,2 prozent höher
in diesem jahr also könnten sie
jederzeit entlassungen vornehmen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen für uns ist die
abschaffung der kalten progression immer
eine selbstverständlichkeit gewesen die
wir alle zwei jahre wie vereinbart
durchgeführt haben liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen entweder sie können die krise
nicht
oder sie wollen es
bewusst so und beides ist verheerend für
den standort deutschland
wenn ein betrieb erst mal zu macht und
sich verlagert
dann macht er nicht mehr auf und das
land verändert sich kolossal der
deutsche mittelstand ist unser stolz und
ist die stärke in unsere wirtschaft wenn
sie diesen kaputt machen und das machen
sie gerade dann legen sie axt an die
gesellschaft in deutschland und an unser
miteinander in unserem land was wir
brauchen liebe kolleginnen kollegen wir
brauchen einsparungen im haushalt sie
sagen sie sparen personal ein dann
kürzen sie auch die stellen sie haben
10.000 neue stellen geschaffen in der
neuen regierung also erzählen sie doch
nichts von personalkürzungen ziehen sie
es wenn durch 4000 stellen könnten sie
mit diesen 1,5 prozent einzigen das tun
sie mit diesem haushalt nicht und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit einer 20
stunden work-life-balance einstellung
werden wir die volkswirtschaft nicht
schaffen sondern wir müssen
arbeitsanreize setzen ich komme auch zum
schluss wir müssen arbeitsanreize setzen
respektiert aber nicht wenn wir kürzen
zum beispiel wenn die rentnerinnen und
rentnern die rentner arbeiten kürzen wir
dann die witwenrente übrigens sicher
auch zum schluss singen gleich fertigen
oder wenn sie die sanktionen gegen
arbeitslose abschaffen so schaffen wir
nicht arbeit und nur mit arbeit und
wachstum kommen wir aus der krise wir
bieten an ihnen zu helfen wir bieten an
in die gespräche zu gehen aber das muss
auch frauen gemessen wird so lehren
kollegen herzlichen dank
so sebastian bremen aus der csu
landesgruppe der sprecher für haushalt
und finanzen hat förmlich oder quasi die
eben übergang eingeleitet für die letzte
runde in dieser allgemeinen
finanzdebatte da wären die
finanzpolitiker noch ein bisschen ein
übergewicht haben und da ist der nächste
redner jetzt
andreas nein michael schuldig bitte um
entschuldigung finanzpolitischer
sprecher der spd fraktion
die wirtschaft unserer gesellschaft in
den letzten jahrzehnten durchmachen muss
putin führten krieg gegen die ukraine
nicht nur aber diesen angriffskriegs
sondern auch einen krieg er führt einen
krieg mit anderen waffen mit der energie
als waffe nahrungsmittel als waffe er
will staaten die stabilisieren unsere
gesellschaft die stabilisieren in dieser
situation
halten
rednerinnen reden hat der größten
oppositionspartei
hier reden in denen sie
teilweise unsachlich kritisiert keine
eigenen vorschläge
liefern dieser situation halten cdu csu
politiker reden die in erschreckender
weise deutlich machen dass sich diese
ehemals staat haben der kanzlerpartei zu
einer populistischen oppositionspartei
entwickelt das ist in dieser situation
vollkommen unangemessen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und die
bundesregierung haben immer wieder klar
gemacht dass er in dieser situation
wie die menschen die alleine gelassen
werden dass wir einen starken staat
einen starken sozialstaat haben mit dem
wir
auch in der zukunft soziale zusammenhalt
organisieren die ampel koalition hat mit
dem entlastungspaket zum wochenende habe
mit diesem haushalt haben 100 milliarden
die sind dass uns paketes zu den 30
milliarden noch mal 65 dem vorliegen
haushalt ganz genau die richtige antwort
gegeben
als deutschland zusammen wir werden
alles möglichkeiten gute diese krise zu
kommen und das ist das signal das von
diesem haushalt und leistungspaketen
ausgeht meine sehr geehrten damen
dazu gibt es weil es keine klassische
inflation ist sondern eine preisschocks
sind auch nicht die klassischen und
einfachen lösungen für diese probleme
deswegen gibt es verschiedene maßnahmen
der staatssekretär tonga hat es auch
deutlich gemacht wir werden auf der
eigenen seite dafür sorgen dass die
energiepreise dämpfen dass wir damit
auch die inflation dämpfen wir werden
dem markt einen höheren strompreis
bremse einbauen und werden vor allen
dingen dafür sorgen dass leistungslose
das krisenbedingte über gewinne wir
abschöpfen werden und den menschen
zurückgeben es ist auch eine frage der
gerechtigkeit und der stabilität das
unternehmen mit ihren zufalls gewinn zur
bekämpfung der krise beitragen meines
agenten namens apple werden das auf den
weg bringen und wir werden gleichzeitig
auch eine weitere frage der
gerechtigkeit nämlich die globale -
steuert hier auch national auf den weg
bringen die milliarden-einnahmen auf den
staat bedeuten die wir wieder in die
krisenbekämpfung geben können auch das
wird jetzt auf den weg gebracht man den
sehr geehrten damen und herren und
zweitens wir müssen täglich aus
erfahrenem wahlkreis aber auch aus
studien
feststellen das natürlich gerade
diejenigen mit kleinen mit mittleren
einkommen von den hohen teuerungsraten
am stärksten betroffen sind und deswegen
haben wir uns auch darauf geeinigt
weiter mit direktzahlungen die probleme
der menschen abzufedern jetzt im
september
werden für
44 millionen menschen
die energiepreis pauschale 300 euro
ausgezahlt wir werden genau diese
direktzahlungen jetzt auch im nächsten
wochen monaten für die eltern renter für
studierende auf den weg bringen wir
werden natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass
löhne
angemessen steigen müssten dafür sehen
diese zeit partner zuständig aber wenn
sie sich auch darauf einigen dass es
zusätzlich arbeitgeber und
gewerkschaften das ist zusätzliche
zahlungen geben soll die in dieser krise
helfen können die menschen helfen können
dann werden wir dafür sorgen dass wir
bis zu 3000 euro hier freistellen von
steuern und sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
auch das ein wichtiger beitrag zur
krisenbekämpfung meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
und auch für die unternehmen ist
übrigens
gesorgt und noch daran gedacht worden
wir werden energie bringt sie für
unternehmen weiterhin das sogenannte
spitzenausgleich gewähren das sind 1,7
milliarden euro
an entlastungen für unternehmen und die
umsatzsteuer senke in der gastronomie
werden wir auch verlängern auch das
deutliche signale hinein in die betriebe
in die unternehmen dass wir hier an
jeder seite stehen meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir werden diese
beiträge in diesem haushalt mit dieser
das paketen eindringen der
oppositionsführer hat gesagt er möchte
die zusammenarbeit anbieten
da stellt sich doch mal die frage
welches angebot gilt denn da
herr merz beklagt die angebotslücke bei
der energieversorgungs der gleichen merz
der im märz das gas embargo
vorgeschlagen hätte die preise in die
höhe getrieben hätte die energielücke
noch größer gemacht denn was gilt denn
nun meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
von der cdu/csu an der stelle ein kommen
sie begeht dem schluss es ist dasselbe
herr wert der meere
unterstützungsleistungen will aber
weltkrieg gegen mindestlohn agitiert hat
gegen die stabilisierung des
rentenniveaus agitiert was gilt denn de
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
von der cdu/csu juli letzter satz beten
wenn wir die unfall geschwindigkeit
qualität geschwindigkeit von herrn merz
energie umwandeln könnten keine
energiekrise so müssen wir wird dafür
sorgen und werden das tun für
energiesicherheit zu sorgen die sich an
boni durch die krise zu bringen und da
machen wir uns am koalition geschlossen
an die arbeit
michael schrodi muss jetzt mal zweimal
ermahnt werden von mark was der
bundestags-vizepräsident ihm die das
ansonsten ihr doch relativ locker laufen
lässt was die redezeiten angeht und was
die redezeiten angeht ist jetzt andreas
odrich strand für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen da ist er
stellvertretender vorsitzender
das werde ich genauso tun frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir gehen auch einen sehr
schwierigen winter zu das wissen wir
alle und das was jetzt im mittelpunkt
stehen muss ist dass wir solidarisch
sind und dass wir alle menschen gut
durch diese zeit bringen und das dritte
entlastungspaket was am wochenende
verhandelt wurde ist ein wichtiger
schritt auch genau diesen weg
unsere grüne logo bei den verhandlungen
zu diesem entlastungspaket war die hilfe
muss bei denen ankommen die es am
härtesten getroffen hat und die es am
härtesten trifft und ich sage ganz offen
nicht jede maßnahme in diesem
entlastungspaket erfüllt diesen anspruch
ich hätte anders agiert an vielen
stellen ich hätte nicht menschen die
200.000 die 300.000 euro verdienen auch
noch geld dazugegeben das ist nicht die
logik das ist beileibe nicht das wofür
wir grüne gekämpft haben wir hatten die
menschen mit wenig geld im blick wir
hatten die menschen mit kleinen
einkommen mit mittleren einkommen im
blick und wir haben für die jede menge
rausgeholt
50 euro schwimmer ein paar punkte nennen
50 euro mehr für menschen in der
grundsicherung das ist die höchste
anhebung jemals in im regelsatz und vor
allem wir werden in die
berechnungsmethode hineingehen und die
ändern wir werden sie im kern verändern
künftig inflation auch in der zukunft
mit einbeziehen und damit auch dauerhaft
die regelsätze nach oben schieben das
kindergeld steigt um 18 euro der
kinderzuschlag um 21 euro die grundlage
für eine kindergrundsicherung die wir
auf den weg bringen werden alle im
wohngeld bekommen nochmal 415 euro
heizkostenzuschuss und dann reformieren
wir das wohngeld für studierende für
rentnerinnen gibt es 200 300 euro
strompreis bremse kommt für den basis
verbrauch und vip werden strom und gas
sperren unterbinden das werden wir tun
eine warme wohnung im winter strom für
den alltag das wird für alle garantiert
sein und dafür sorgen wir ich hab gesagt
nicht jede maßnahme die selbst dieses
paketes ist meine aber es gibt einen
wichtigen punkt die gesamt verteilung
verteilungswirkung geht jetzt vor allem
nach unten und in die mitte und das war
die voraussetzung für uns zuzustimmen
das haben wir heraus verhandelt das ist
jetzt im paket und deswegen ist es ein
gutes paket
wir müssen die aktuelle krise bewältigen
und gleichzeitig dürfen wir nicht die
zukunft vergessen deswegen muss klar
sein jeder sektor muss einen beitrag zum
klimaschutz leisten und das gilt auch
für den verkehrssektor wir haben auch an
der stelle jede menge rausgeholt am
wochenende das neun euro ticket wird
eine nachfolge bekommen das haben wir
geschafft und zweitens da haben sie herr
bremen offentlichtlich am wochenende ein
nickerchen gemacht es sei ihnen gegönnt
aber bislang war die finanzierung der
schiene zu tief das ist richtig wir
haben verhandelt jetzt haben wir 1,5
milliarden euro noch einmal draufgelegt
so macht man politik so macht man
klimaschutz und genau das haben wir am
wochenende auf dem weg gebracht
ein weiterer punkt ist mir wichtig der
diktator putin der greift uns hier mit
gaspreisen und propaganda an der
diktator putin greift in anderen teilen
der welt mit hungerkrisen an annalena
baerbock hat eine außenpolitik neu
definiert die dieser harten
auseinandersetzung gerecht wird und
darum ist es so wichtig dass wir dann
wenn es drauf man kommt nicht am geld
sparen auch das ist eine sache die wir
uns ganz genau angeschaut haben und
deswegen ist es so wichtig um diese
antwort geben zu können dass wir noch
einmal eine milliarde euro für
ernährungssicherung draufpacken die
botschaft ist klar wir kümmern uns um
die ärmsten und wir geben dem diktator
putin keinen raum das gilt für
deutschland und das gilt gleichermaßen
weltweit
der winter der hat noch nicht begonnen
und wir sehen jetzt schon dass die
herausforderungen riesig werden und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir jetzt
über gewinne im strommarkt abschöpfen um
zu sagen wir brauchen dieses geld und
das heißt auch für die zukunft für die
nächsten monate wir können uns aus
dieser krise nicht heraussparen und wir
werden unsere politik auch in den
kommenden monaten nicht an dogmen aus
wahlprogrammen festmachen sondern an der
realität das ist der grundsatz die ampel
wird verantwortung übernehmen genau das
machen wir zusammen und deswegen ist es
ein guter weg den wir gemeinsam
beschreiten können dankeschön zu sankt
andreas ott stellvertretender
vorsitzender der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen im bundestag und damit ist er der
drittletzte redner in dieser allgemeinen
finanzdebatte gewesen in zu deren beginn
der parlamentarische staatssekretär
tonka den bundeshaushalt zur 23 hier
eingebracht hat jetzt christoph meyer
fdp auch er ist stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
politischen normalität da haben die
zahlen bereits gehört 445 milliarden
euro über 50 milliarden euro
investitionssumme dass es mehr als im
letzten
unions entwurf beinhaltet war für das
jahr 2023 und wir sind trotz der krisen
ausgewogen unterwegs trotz der des
zustandes des landes ausgewogen
unterwegs auf der einen seite
investieren wir auf der einen seite
treffen wir vorsorge für die krise und
auf der anderen seite halten wir die
neuverschuldung niedrig auf 17,2
milliarden euro damit halten wir die
schuldenbremse ein und das ist ein gutes
zeichen nach drei jahren ausnahmezustand
und wir werden das und wir werden das
auch für die jahre 2004 und 20 25
sicherstellen am ende des tages werden
wir dafür sorge tragen dass wir jetzt
die grundlagen schaffen dieses land vor
zu vorzubereiten auf die nächsten krisen
und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen herr
mittelberg und herr bremen ich kann das
aus ihrer perspektive verstehen wenn sie
nach der argumentation was interessiert
uns unsere zeit in der unionsgeführten
bundesregierung was interessiert uns an
verantwortung was wir damals an
versäumnissen haben dass alles schön und
gut aber ihr gedächtnis geht noch nicht
mal bis zu den haushaltsberatungen 20 22
zurück da waren sie ist da war es die
union die die asyl rücklage in höhe von
48 milliarden euro auflösen wollte sie
waren ist die uns genau hier jetzt das
vorwerfen was sie damals wollten und
dann muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen so
billig kommen sie hier nicht davon
und das gilt für alle anderen vorwürfe
die sie hier gemacht haben auch das ist
der bereich stellen aufwuchs das sind
vor allem stellen im bereich zoll im
bereich bundespolizei sind sie denn
dagegen dass der zoll besser
ausgestattet wird oder die bundespolizei
das müssten sie doch mal sagen das ist
doch der eigentliche skandal den sie
hier uns mitteilen wollen
so was interessiert mich mein geschwätz
von gestern das scheint offensichtlich
die devise sein mit der die union
mittlerweile haushaltspolitik macht dass
es schaden und das gilt auch zb für den
ganzen bereich zinsen sie haben immer
noch nicht verstanden wo der unterschied
liegt zwischen zinsen und zinskosten
das ist nämlich das problem was wir
haben dass wir von der
vorgängerregierung von der
unionsgeführten regierung hier ob das
das thema inflationsausgleich ist oder
das radio ist wir hier kosten die
ausgeben müssen als zusatzkosten zu dem
steigenden zins als solches und deswegen
ist ihre gesamte argumentation hier
leider nicht sehr viel wert wir halten
die schuldenbremse ein wir entlasten die
mittel mit dem abbau der kalten
progression das haben sie uns alles
nicht zugetraut ich gehe davon aus dass
wir bis november intensive
haushaltsberatungen haben aber am ende
des tages werden wir einen genauso guten
haushalt verabschieden wie er jetzt im
entwurf vorliegt ich danke ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auf die
beratung
christoph meyer kurz und bündig für die
fdp-fraktion das liegt auch daran dass
habe ich ihnen vorenthalten das mag was
die redezeiten jetzt hier am ende noch
mal ein bisschen gekürzt hat was im
vorfeld nicht so wirklich aus dem ruder
gelaufen war aber doch ein bisschen
undiszipliniert vonstattengegangen ist
deswegen muss hier jetzt eingespart
werden am ende auch bei frauke
heiligenstadt aus der spd-fraktion
geübt am vorliegenden
haushaltsplanentwurf versucht kein
einziges gutes haar an den vorschlägen
der bundesregierung festung der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu lassen daher
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu
müssen sie sich auch gefallen lassen
dass wir uns ihre vorschläge eben mal
angeschaut haben deshalb habe ich mir
mal ihr papier von anfang september mit
der überschrift klarheit in unsicheren
zeiten vorgenommen und nachgeschaut was
sie denn so anders machen würden so
fordern sie zum beispiel die abschaffung
der gasanlage sie erklären den menschen
allerdings nicht mit welchen mitteln aus
dem haushalt sie die insolvenzen bei den
versorgungsunternehmen abwenden und
damit auch die gasversorgung
sicherstellen wollen klarheit in unseren
zeiten fehlanzeige
nehmen wir einmal den punkt zur
atomkraft sie fordern die deutliche
weiter nutzung der atomenergie sogar
einschließlich des erwerbs von neuen
kernbrennstäben dem ganzen thema widmen
sie in ihrem papier übrigens sage und
schreibe elf zeilen unkonkreter
formulierungen sie berücksichtigen dabei
aber die weder die kosten eines
weiterbetriebs von atomkraftwerken
genauso wenig also wie den erwerb von
kernbrennstäben oder mögliche
schadenersatzforderungen der
atomindustrie die die kosten des
ausstiegs aus dem ausstieg vom ausstieg
sicherlich thematisieren werden klarheit
in unsicheren zeiten fehlanzeige
ein weiteres beispiel ist ihre
abwrackprämie
für energiefresser sind so unkreativ
dass sie alte ideen aus dem letzten
jahrzehnt die damals auch schwierig
funktioniert haben einfach recycelt sie
fordern also jetzt die abwrackprämie für
kühlschränke
mal abgesehen davon dass die bürgerinnen
und bürger momentan häufig gar kein geld
für neue geräte haben könnten sie mit
den von ihnen vorgeschlagenen drei
millionen geräten vielleicht gerade noch
mal berlin die haushalt in berlin aus
starten aber für den rest der republik
bräuchten sie deutlich mehr geld
finanzieren klarheit in unsicheren
zeiten
fehlanzeige meine damen und herren ich
könnte aus ihrem papier noch ein paar
weitere punkte nennen die entweder sehr
unkonkret sind und keinerlei
finanzierungs hinweise beinhalten ich
belasse es jetzt aber mal bei diesen
drei beispielen bei der
gesamtfinanzierung des haushaltes
fordern sie ohnehin immer nur mehr mehr
mehr wenn es um die fachpolitiker geht
während ihre finanzpolitiker und
finanzpolitikerin und haushaltspolitiker
immer sagen schuldenbremse einhalten und
keine steuern erhöhen oder keine abgaben
erhöhen beides zusammen funktioniert
aber auch nicht kurzum sie können hier
vorschläge machen so viel sie wollen
vielleicht ist das was für sommerloch
wenn sie aber wieder ernst genommen
werden wollen mit ihren vorschlägen dann
müssen sie schon
regierungsfähige vorschläge machen
ansonsten liegen bleibt mir nichts
anderes zu sagen man braucht die union
in der opposition weniger als jetzt
frauke heiligenstadt aus der
spd-fraktion war die letzte rednerin in
der allgemeinen finanzdebatte die
traditionell die haushaltswoche eröffnet
nachdem der haushalt eingebracht worden
war von florian tonga dem
parlamentarischen staatssekretär beim
bundesfinanzminister in vertretung von
christian lindner des vorfalls heute
hier nicht sein konnte